and Community I honed a lot of skills
that I didn't know were like valuable we
must have changed like a sound Cruise
like every I'm not joking like maybe
every six weeks I don't know why like it
just happened that way so I would have
to ADR and I thought you and I would ADR
entire episodes and I thought that was
normal same thing with the Improv thing
I thought that was television I thought
that's just what you did they would be
like yeah and then Donald says something
funny I am the truest repairman and I
was like okay that's like that's
Hollywood so I would just
I would I I I think the first season I
was like really nervous about it but
once I realized like oh you can do this
again and again and again and it'll be
fine it really let me like be loose and
also I was like friends with those guys
so I didn't feel like nervous about like
we were always trying to make each other
laugh